hey hang on is this the only episode of
modern era doctor who to have snow in it
but not be a christmas episode
[Music]
thin ice and we continue as we get
through series 10 of doctor who and we
get our first
past set episode which is fitting we had
a
few random jaunts around the universe in
the pilot and then
in the second episode we got to go on
another world and also a little bit into
the future
and now here we're back on earth but
it's the past
and i like this a lot more than i like a
fair number of the past set episodes
mainly because it's missing the one
thing that usually drives me the most
crazy about the past set episodes
which is it's there is no celebrity
historical figure
there's a historical event the frost
fair
but there's no there's no dickens
there's no queen victoria there's no
winston churchill there's none of that
and not to say that every single time
that's happened in
a historical set episode it hasn't
worked for me but i am going to say that
most of the things that annoy me about
historical set episodes have a tendency
to tie back in
to that sort of thing so thankfully with
that not being present this for the most
part works for me pretty well
first of all i like that it's an
accidental trip
i feel like it's i i'm not i'm not going
to go back and check
for certain the last time this happened
but i feel like at this point in the
series it had been a while since the
doctor had done the
right place wrong time landing the
tardis sort of thing
and i mean especially with the 12th
doctor really seemed like he had a bit
more of a handle on landing exactly
where he wanted to
it's kind of nice to have a little
reminder that no no
not always also bill continues her trend
of
asking these interesting questions that
are the kinds of things that
well fans but also like people who just
think differently than most of the
companions the doctors had up to this
point will ask things like the butterfly
effect which i really like
the way that that gets brushed off every
choice i make in this moment
here and now could change the whole
future exactly like every other day of
your life the only thing to do
is to start worrying about it i love
that because from his perspective
there's no difference everything that i
mean it's true of her life as well but
he has the perspective of a time
traveler to just
know that like yeah no it's called
existing just roll with it
so i dug that and the
setting is a lot of fun it's nice to see
bill in uh in that outfit and the doctor
uh with the top hat yeah that that kind
of works for me
i'm glad that wasn't like a permanent
addition oh
i actually have a top hat i should have
worn it i am too lazy to start this
video over and go get it
i'm sorry but in any case
the thing that we get here again sort of
we've been running into this thing uh in
lately that
i feel where elements of episodes
seem like they're remixes of either
earlier ideas or earlier features that
were seen in the show and honestly by
series 10
i'm kind of okay with that if you can
give me something that feels wholly
original
yes please do but if you can't
revisiting
elements or themes or ideas that have
been done before but just finding a way
to present them in a new
fashion yeah that works for me
especially in more
episodic self-contained kind of episodes
which ultimately
setting aside the mystery box series
arcs most
doctor who episodes are the show has
never really gone fully serialized in
the modern era
so we have this thing under the ground
and is being
used for fuel basically it is a new riff
on kind of the core concept of what was
going on in the beast below
but again between it being set on earth
the motivation behind it being
completely different and purely selfish
as opposed to we thought this was the
only way the human race could survive
it's different enough that even though i
can recognize that as a similar core
element
the story built around it is not the
same and i'm good with that although
i did like that the doctor said well
let's try and get eaten by it and my
immediate thought was yeah like you did
in the beast below yeah of course you
would think that would work it worked
last time
there's another bit that i really like
from bill i like bill observing
regency england a bit more black than
showing the movies
so it was jesus this is a whitewash
you may choose to label that as a
political statement but it's also true
like the simple fact is that we have a
tendency to depict
the past with only
whoever was the people in power being
the ones who are shown unless there's a
specific story driven reason to do it
so you get something set in victorian
england you don't see
people from asia you don't see black
skinned people you don't
see this diversity you just see a whole
bunch of white people as if these other
people weren't even there
but they were and they just generally
don't get depicted and they certainly
weren't getting written about at the
time
so that's just a nice thing and like
this isn't supposition on my part there
is
there was work and research on the
demographics of what the population was
actually like especially in a city like
london with a huge commerce city of
course it had higher diversity than you
usually see in shows so
i like that it didn't hammer on that but
i also like that it was acknowledged
again like
little things are getting brought up and
pointed out
through bill and it's just one more
reason that i really do enjoy
bill another thing she has
i would say an impressively uh
shaken response to
a child getting killed which first off
the show killed a kid
okay like i'm not i don't remember the
last time that happened
school reunion maybe and actually bugged
me when it happened in school reunion
because it was part of the cold open and
as a result it felt very callous
here thanks largely to bill's reaction
of
being just stunned by this and
turned her first reaction to turn to the
doctor and say save
him and to the doctor this is not a new
situation she's just going
i can't it's too late i can't bill does
not want to accept that and then
she she didn't have like a proper
sobbing breakdown but she like she
runs and she goes in the corner she's
like she's trying to process the fact
that she just watched somebody die and
the doctor just point out you were in a
garden full of dead bodies before like
yes but i didn't watch it happen
they were already dead when i got there
and for a human experience
there is a difference that matters and i
like that the show
put the emphasis on what that kind of
experience would be
for somebody who especially somebody who
really stumbled into this and didn't
come in
going yeah let's have an adventure i
mean let's remember
her first adventure with the doctor yes
heather died but again she didn't see
that happening and it was it all
happened so
fast that really and she kind of did get
a chance to say goodbye so she was able
to process that and then in smile
she wasn't there when it happened so
she's coming in almost like an
archaeologist
so to really properly emphasize yeah
people die when they're with the doctor
and i like that she doesn't just leave
it at that
like ultimately the doctor saying i move
on is something that she
brings on board because she kind of
comes to the realization of if
i'm going to help at all i need to move
forward and that is going to involve a
certain amount of moving on from this
thing that happened that i can't change
but i like that she doesn't let him wuss
out
she gets right in his face have you ever
killed anyone
and he tries to dodge it he tries to
give the kinds of
answers that previous doctors either
would have or in some cases did try to
give
there are situations where the options
available are limited no i asked
sometimes the choices that's not what i
asked
she pins him down and will not let him
back off this point until
he gives a yes or no answer and i don't
think this is just about bill
asking the question i think the fact
that the doctor though he was reluctant
to do it
does just say yes
and is willing to say that not
comfortable saying it
but willing to say it because you look
back even at tenant
when he had his conversation with wilf
in the end of time part two and i love
that conversation on the ship
it's gold but even there where he is
chastising himself
for the mistakes he has made and the
things he has done even then he's saying
i've let people die or
convince them into doing something that
would get themselves killed he'll admit
to that but he still won't say the words
i
have killed people
it's a big thing for him to admit to
this
and again it just leads into the growth
that i've gotten to see
from the 12th doctor over his time in
the role
it's really good okay so let's get to
the villain
and some of the commentary that's going
on
with this this is here's the thing
i was going to say this is a bit of a
social commentary season
that's a little bit true but also that's
a little bit misleading because it
implies that social commentary hasn't
been a part of doctor who since
literally the 1960s and its very first
story
so that's disingenuous to imply and i'm
not intending to do that
but what i will say is that social
commentary is a running
theme that is being revisited across the
series
in a way that hasn't really been up to
this point now
doctor who separate from the mystery box
story arcs that it tends to do
often has running themes going through
it
whether it be things like just being too
casual around danger which is kind of
what we got going on in
series two the the toxicity
and the sort of recursive
feeding each other's worst impulses that
we got going on between clara and the
doctor in series nine that was your
running theme from episode
to episode so those sorts of things are
usually there this
is the first time that i can think of
off the top of my head where the social
commentary isn't a one-off in an episode
here an episode there but that's
kind of a part of the recurring thing
and we get
it we got a little bit um honestly and
smile
with the whole thing about having to
accept and acknowledge
the robots as being their own species
and
having to come to terms with that and
here we have sutcliffe we have our
villain
who is just a capitalist bastard
that is just what he is he is it's not a
case of he doesn't realize the damage
that is being done
by the thing that makes him money he's
fully aware he just
doesn't care and i'm sorry if you think
that's
villainizing of capitalism as a system
but that is what capitalism tends to
breed
are all capitalists and all people who
run businesses in a capitalist society
like this
no but people who are willing to behave
like this
will be financially rewarded for the
things they do
as he has been and also i really love
that the doctor
basically preps bill to be to just sit
there and take whatever this guy's going
to dish out in terms of racism because
he knows like
okay this is going to go badly and he
has this line that he says to bill
always remember bill passion fights
but reason wins and that
you know what i'm not necessarily going
to argue that that's incorrect but i
love that he himself
undercuts that by decking sutcliffe
as soon as the guy makes it clear
exactly how much contempt
open contempt he has for the fact that
there is a black person
even in his presence and that person has
not subjugated themselves to him
the doctor just belts him cuz you know
what
i can go with the general philosophy
that passion fights and reason wins but
you know what if reason's not gonna get
you there
sometimes you gotta throw a punch and i
love that the doctor did that and i love
that
that contrast because it's not hypocrisy
it's not a contradiction the fact that
he said that but still
landed a punch that is stating your
intended philosophical stance
and then having a moment where like well
that's not gonna work is it
boom so i love that that worked really
well
i like that the way that the doctor kind
of
pulls bill back into the because bill is
kind of wavering kind of
around the climax like what do we do do
we
save this thing under the ice
what do we do now and the doctor says i
serve at the pleasure of the human
species now i don't know if that's an
exact repeat but it's a repeat of the
sentiment
from kill the moon so you might think
i'd be like oh for god's sake because it
annoyed me when he did that and kill the
moon
it doesn't annoy me here because the
reason
he says this at least my reading on it
my head cannon on it
is not so much him deferring
responsibility to bill
but trying to pull her back into the
situation
this is his hook in so that she just
doesn't detach
and is just like i i can't and sort of
tunes out
it's like no i need you here i need you
here now and i'm gonna make you be here
now
by forcing you to make this decision by
saying i serve at the pleasure of the
human race
now is that the intended reading i don't
know it's my reading i like it
so overall this is a pretty good solid
well put together episode definitely for
the historical ones which again
i have a tendency not to be as big a fan
of but this one works
pretty dang well especially as it builds
the relationship between
bill and the doctor i really do love
their dynamic it's probably my second
favorite modern era doctor who
um pairing right behind tennant and
donna
but seriously this is a great pairing
these two are work
wonderfully off each other and getting
more of that does a bit to elevate what
would otherwise be a
good maybe not great episode but you
know with that added in and feeling like
it's developing all of that it just
boosts it up a little bit more
i do really like this one oh uh one
other thing
i do feel like i i get that this was
probably unintended
but a thought occurred to me at the very
end where there's the knocking from the
vault
which you know the pace at which they
parse out information about the vault
actually truth be told i need to like
have a
i need to do a bigger discussion on the
mystery box series arcs
at some point and how they do or don't
work for me and which ones work better
i actually like that the vault is
something that we learn
one new thing about it pretty much every
single time it's shown
the fact that someone knocks from the
inside means that oh it's something
live in there it's not just holding
a resource information no it's a person
and like maybe you could assess that out
but that's your confirmation but what i
was trying to get at before i went on a
tangent
hey was that uh it is a little bit
irritating that it ends with the knocks
from the vault and the next episode is
called knock knock
and it has nothing to do with any of
that that feels like a bit of a mislead
although
it's probably accidental because given
that what the next episode
is and you know the knock on wood puns
and that it's in a house where
knocking is part of the scares or
whatever
probably didn't mean that to happen but
it does make me oh for god's sake
so that's thin ice have you rewatched it
lately what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it i feel like i went
more rapid fire today than usual i am
high energy today i don't know why
what are your thoughts about about that
i suppose um
also i have a patreon which is what
enables me to eat
and keeps this entire channel up and
running if you're able to support me in
any amount that is greatly appreciated
and there are perks to doing so but even
if you can't
like share subscribe they all help me
out the algorithm is not being kind to
my doctor who content of
late uh and i know part of that is new
episodes aren't currently airing but it
didn't
used to be this bad even in the off
season so any help would is appreciated
but you also don't
have to because at the end of the day
you are the council
i am only running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
oh
[Music]